[موسيقى]
مساء الخير العالم كله بيعيش في فوضى
لاسباب سوف تخصص لها حلقه قريبه مقبله لكن
احنا النهارده بنتكلم على الشرق الاوسط
الشرق الاوسط جزء من العالم صحيح لكن
الفوضى اللي بيعيشها الشرق الاوسط لها
خصوصيه اذا اردت ان تفهم ما يجري في الشرق
الاوسط بكلمه واحده فهي في تقديري كلمه
فراغ ضع كلمه فراغ في جمله لها معنى كما
يقولون لنا في المدارس اين كنا اطفال
الشرق الاوسط يعيش في سنوات الفراغ وما
معنى الفراغ انعدام قوه الجاذبيه
وما هي قوه الجاذبيه التي كانت تضبط
استقرار الشرق الاوسط القوه المركزيه التي
كانت تحكم هذه المنطقه من العالم شرق
الاوسط طوال تاريخه كان بيعيش تحت حكمه
قوه مركزيه بطبقه حركه الدول التي تعيش في
هذا الاقليم الحيوي من العالم لكن القوه
المركزيه دي تعرضت الى الاضعاف وتبخرت على
مدار 100 سنه من خلال خمسه مراحل
والنتيجه ان الشرق الاوسط الان من
افغانستان وباكستان وايران في الشرق الى
المغرب في الغرب ومن السودان في الجنوب
الى تركيا في الشمال
بيعيش لاول مره في تاريخه بلا قوه مركزيه
طبقه حركته والدول اللي بتعيش في هذا
الاقليم بتدير شؤونها لاول مره بنفسها في
تاريخها وذكر حضراتكم انه دول المنطقه
كلها كانت على مدار قرون تحت سلطه مركزيه
كبيره مثلا الدول المنطقه لقرون وحتى
الحرب العالميه الاولى كان معظمها بيعيش
تحت سلطه الامبراطوريه العثمانيه
انهارت الامبراطوريه العثمانيه بعد الحرب
العالميه الاولى اللي انتهت في سنه 1918
وانهيار الامبراطوريه العثمانيه كان اول
تحول درامي نحو الفراغ الذي نعيش فيه الان
حل محل الامبراطوريه العثمانيه القوه
الاوروبيه الاستعماريه وخاصه بريطانيا
وفرنسا اللي احتلت معظم دول المنطقه تحت
غطاء الامتداب
ثم تراجع نفوض الدول الاوروبيه بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وبدات دول المنطقه تحصل
على استقلالها اتباعا منذ الاربعنات من
القرن الماضي ده كان خروج الدول الاوروبيه
دي التحول الثاني الدرامي نحو الفراغ الذي
نعيش فيه الان
حل محل بريطانيا وفرنسا
انظمه شموليه مركزيه قويه بتحكم سيطرتها
على الدول التي تحكمها زي الحبيب بورقيبه
في تونس جمال عبد الناصر في مصر زي حافظ
الاسد في سوريا زي معمر القذافي في ليبيا
الى اخره لكن كل الانظمه دي كانت بشكل او
باخر اما متحالفه مع الولايات المتحده يا
اما متحالفه مع الاتحاد السوفيتي
جاء التحول الدرامي الثالث حين انهار
الاتحاد السوفيتي في نهايه 1991
في 2011 جاء التحول الدرامي الرابع حين ان
حارت كثير من الانظمه الشموليه التي كانت
تحكم دول المنطقه بعد ثورات الربيع العربي
كثير من الانظمه دي انهار كما حدث في
ليبيا وكما حدث في اليمن
وكما حدث الى حد كبير في سوريا الى اخره
ده كان التحول الرابع ماذا تبقى من القوه
المركزيه اللي بتحكم المنطقه الولايات
المتحده الولايات المتحده على مدار 12 او
ال 15 سنه الماضيه بتضعف سلطتها بشكل
تدريجي وشكل واضح تراجع نفوذها وتراجعت
شهيتها لاحكام سيطرتها على دول المنطقه
وده التحول الدرامي الخامس نحو الفراغ
الذي نعيش فيه الان احنا بنعيش في هذه
المرحله
المرحله دي ليها خصائص من بين الخصائص
الواضحه طبعا انه مع التراجع نفوذ
الولايات المتحده ان كثير من حلفاءها في
دول المنطقه
بينفضوا عنها او بتضعف العلاقه بينهم وبين
الولايات المتحده الامثله على ده كثيره
جدا يعني مثلا مؤخرا الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها بجلاله قدرهم بيقولوا لدول
الاوبك زودوا انتاج البترول الاجابه لا
الولايات المتحده بجلاله قدرها
بتطلب من دول المنطقه ان يصطفوا معها في
مواجهه روسيا
وبتطالبهم بادانه روسيا ومحاوله الانضمام
اليها لمحاصره الروس والضغط عليهم وبتكون
الايجابه ايضا لا الولايات المتحده بتطلب
من دول المنطقه ان هم يقللوا من الدفاعهم
نحو الصين وبتكون الاجابه ايضا لا لا ده
اول ملمح من ملامح المرحله التي نعيش فيها
الان
الملمح الثاني البديهي اذا ضعفت علاقه هذه
الدول بالولايات المتحده هي بتقوى في
الحقيقه مع دول اخرى مع الصين طبعا مع
روسيا طبعا مع الهند طبعا هذا هو الملمح
الثاني
الملمح الثالث انه الدول دي اللي بتدير
شؤونها لاول مره بنفسها هي بتتصف الاداره
بكثير من التقلب والاضطراب والفوضى
وبتنتقل العلاقات في هذه المنطقه من
العالم ما بين الاكستريم والاكستريم يعني
اقصى اليمين لاقصى اليسار من علاقات
الصداقه لعلاقات العداء ومن علاقات العداء
ليه علاقات التوتر الشديد ومن التوتر
الشديد للود والصداقه وتلطيف الاجواء
لان في فراغ اعطيكم امثله كثيره جدا
بعد 2011 دول المنطقه وجدت انه هناك فراغ
بتحاول تواجه الفراغ ده كل دوله بتحاول ان
هي تواجهه بالادوات التي تعتقد انها
تحكمها تحكم السيطره عليها وسوف تصب في
مصلحتها
دول المنطقه في المرحله دي انقسمت على
محورين واضحين
فوضى صحيح لكن الانقسام في هذه الفوضى كان
على محورين واضحين المحور الاول مع
الاخوان ضد الاخوان والمحور الثاني مع
ايران ده ايران
على سبيل المثال بعد ثورات الربيع العربي
ايران تركيا وقطر رات انه
يمكن ان اللحظه والفراغ اللي موجود يمكن
ان يتم استغلاله عشان يوسعوا نفوذهم على
حساب الدول الاخرى وبدات الدولتان
بالاستعانه بجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
وحاولوا الاطاحه بعدد من الانظمه ونجحوا
في التمدد في الفراغ اللي كان موجود في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط ودي قصه تحدثنا عنها
كثيرا قبل ذلك وسوف اعيد كتابه الروابط او
نشر الروابط عشان نشرح الخلفيه اللي تحركت
فيها تركيا وقطر وعاشت المنطقه سنوات
نتيجه التحرك التركي القطري
السعوديه والامارات تحديدا
قادوا الهجوم المضاد على تركيا وقطر وعشنا
سنوات اخرى في الهجوم والهجوم المضاد
القاسم المشترك او الاطار اللي كانوا
بيتحرك فيه الفريقين مع الاخوان او ضد
الاخوان لكن بين قوسين كل طرف بيحاول ان
يعظم بكاسبه بعيدا عن الاخوان الاخوان ده
اطار كده بيتحركوا فيه
المحور الثاني كان مع ايران او ضد ايران
هذا المحور مازال موجوده اما ان تكون مع
ايران بتحاول ان تواجهها او بتحاول ان انت
تتاقلم معه وجودها
الدول في مواجهتها مع بعضها البعض في
محاوله اداره شؤونها لاول مره في تاريخها
عملت كل ما يمكن ان تتصور انه مفيد لها
استخدموا اسلوب المواجهه زي زي قطر وتركيا
وزي الامارات والسعوديه لاحقا وتواجهه على
محاور مختلفه زي سوريا زي ليبيا زي
الصومال زي كثير من الدول
ثم اكتشفوا بعد سنوات طويله ان هذه
المواجهه غير مقضيه ما فيش طرف عنده وفاقه
قوه ان يفرض ارادته على الطرف الاخر ابرز
مثال ابرز مثال على محور الاخوان ضد
الاخوان يعني تركيا بعد سنوات طويله ادرك
الرئيس التركي انه غير قادر على فرد
مشروعه واضطر انه يمد يده الى الدول التي
عاداها
وكانت مصافحه للرئيس السيسي اللي هو
الرئيس المصري في افتتاح كاس العالم ايفان
بانه انا غير قادر على فرد مشروعي وان
الصراع على الاخوان ضد الاخوان صفحه وطويت
ولو مؤقتا
سبقها كان الصراع مع قطر ودول الخليج قطر
اراد التغيير دول المنطقه بشكل يعني يعظم
من مكاسبها رد الدول المنطقه الاربعه
البحرين والامارات والسعوديه
ومصر بحصار على قطر او بمقاطعه كبيره على
قطر ثم ادركت هذه الدول الاربعه ان هي غير
قادره على تركيا قطر لوحدها لان قطر لا
تعمل في فراغ وبتشتغل هي كمان مع دول اخرى
لا قطر وحلفائها قادرين على فرد سيطرتهم
على هذا الرباعي ولا هذا الرباعي قادر على
يعني الترقيع قطر نهائيا وبالتالي اضطر
الطرفين ان هم يعني في مطلع 21 ان هم
يتصالحوا وتصفو الاجواء تدريجيا
على محور ايران ضد ايران مرينا بمراحل
كثيره جدا
يعني مثلا دول الخليج بعض دول الخليج التي
قطعت ايران بعد 2016 هو صحفا سفرائها من
طهران عادت فيه اغسطس من هذا العام لتعيد
سفرائها مره اخرى مثل الامارات مثل الكويت
وترسل رسائل واضحه انا لا ارغب في عداء
ولا في فتح مواجهه مع ايران السعوديه اللي
هي اكثر دول المنطقه عداءا لايران طبعا
جربت كل وسائل المواجهه مع ايران زي ما
ايران جربت كله وسائل الضغط على السعوديه
ثم ادركت الدولتان ان هذه المواجهه لا
طائله منها فنجات الى سوبر التفاوض
وتفاوضوا في 2020 سرا مع عن طريق العراق
وبواساطه عمانيه
على امل انه يلجاوا ان يحققوا بالمفاوضات
ما فاشله فيه بوسائل الضغط الخشن ثم
انهارت هذه او تعثرت هذه المفاوضات وعادت
وسائل المواجهه الخشنه مره اخرى كل
الوسائل الخشنه ما عدا الاستخدام القوه
العسكريه المباشره على الصعيد الايراني
قبل الخطا قبل الخطوات ديت كانت دول
الخليج لاجئت الى اتفاقات الابراهيميه
اللي هو عقد علاقات واسعه مع اسرائيل املا
في تدعيم موقفهم في مواجهه ايران
الامر الذي اثار غضب ايران بشده وبالتالي
وجدت هذه الدول ان عليها ان هي تعمل نوع
من التوازن وزي ما قلت لحضراتكم الى
التفاوض معه على الاراضي العراقيه او
اعاده العلاقات مع ايران او مثلا انسحاب
الامارات همم
همم او تقليل دورها على الاقل فيه اليمن
احنا قدام محورين محور بيضوي وبيضعف اللي
هي المواجهه بين دول المنطقه على اساس مع
الاخوان ضد الاخوان وهذا الملف بيطول وان
كان مؤقتا ولكن قدامنا ملف ما زال شائك
دول المنطقه بتنقسم حوله مع ايران او ضد
ايران ليه الملف ده ما زال القائم ببساطه
لان دول المنطقه غير قادره على التعايش او
كثير منها غير قادر على التعايش مع الخطر
الايراني عليها
وهم عاجزون على مواجهه ايران وحدهم حتى لو
اجتمعت كل الدول اللي هي بتشعر بالخطر
الايراني تحديدا الدول الخليج مع اسرائيل
غير قادرين على مواجهه ايران وحدهم ما
زالوا في احتياج الى قوه مركزيه قوه
خارجيه اخرى هذه القوه الخارجيه لا يمكن
ان تكون الصين لا يمكن ان تكون روسيا لا
يمكن ان تكون الا الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده غير مستعده
لمواجهه عسكريه مفتوحه مع ايران ولذلك
يبقى هذا الملف مفتوحا
ليسبب الاضطرابات في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ويزيد من الفوضى التي يعيش فيها
انا قلت لحضراتكم في بدايه الحلقه لو عاوز
تلخص ما يجري في منطقه الشرق الاوسط في
كلمه واحده فيها كلمه الفراغ انعدام
الجاذبيه وسوف يظل من تتظل منطقه الشرق
الاوسط تعيش في فراغ للسنوات الى ان تتغير
الظروف العالميه اللي هنخصص لها حلقه
مقبله ان شاء الله لكن انا حابب ان انا
اختم الحلقه دي
يعني بالاشاره الى مفهوم قدمه ممكن برده
يساعدنا ما يجري في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
هذا المفهوم قدمه عالم الاجتماع البولندي
الشهير زيجمنت باوند
او من عالم اجتماع بولندي
توفى اظن في سنه 2017
وعاش معظم حياته في
التدريس في الجامعات الغربيه وتحديد لندن
الراجل ده تحدث عن مفهوم سماه
الليكويد مودرنيتي او الحداثه السائله كان
بيتكلم ايه يقصد ايه بالحداثه السائله
الراجل ما كانش بيتكلم على السياسه كان
بيتكلم على العالم الذي نعيش فيه اليوم
لما نتيجه العولمه اللي خلقها النظام
الراسمالي اللي بيحكم العالم من عشرات
السنوات فكرته كانت بسيطه بيقول الناس
كلها بتعيش حاله من الخوف والاضطراب مين
الناس بيتكلم على هيئه العمل وبيقول
ببساطه كده كان في ما مضى من الزمان
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه قبل العولمه المتوحشه
ديت قتل الاوضاع هادئه الانسان بيقولك ثم
يعني اكتسب مهاره او بيتعلم عشان يبدا
عمله في شركه من الشركات والشركه دي بيظل
فيها الى ان يتقاعد
وكانت الشركه دي عباره عن مصانع كبيره او
صغيره صاحب العمل معروف والعلاقه مباشره
بين صاحب العمل والعامل وطبعا لان العلاقه
مباشره في نقابات في حقوق الى اخره
قدره العام على التعبير عن غضب واضحه
التظاهر الشكوى الى اخره كل شيء تحول
وتغير لا صاحب العمل الان بيعرف العامل
ولا العامل بيعرف صاحب العمل انت ممكن
تعيش واا تعمل الى ان تتقاعد الان وانت لا
تعرف من هو صاحب العمل لان صاحب العمل اا
عباره عن شركه متعدده الجنسيات والشركه
متعدده الجنسيات عندها انشطه في العالم
كله وبتستعين بشركات بتاعها اليها بمهمه
محدده وانت الشركه اللي بتعمل فيها عباره
عن شركه بتتعاقد مع شركه وشركه بتتعاقد مع
شركه تعمل لصالح هذه الشركه الكبيره لا
تستطيع
انك تواجه صاحب العمل باي شكل او تضغط
عليه لان صاحب العمل عنده كل الحدود
مفتوحه استطيع ان ينتقل برؤوس امواله من
المغرب الى
البرتغال الى الصين الى اخره يستطيع ان
يختار مساء من العماله لانه اما انه
يستعين بهم يعملوا له فريلانسنج يعني مثلا
انا عاوز مهندس مثلا سوفت وير باعمل عرض
والعرض بيجيلي من الهند من اندونيسيا من
روسيا الى اخره لو المساله محتاجه علاقه
مباشره اذا ما وجدتش ما يريحني في مصر
استطيع ان انتقل به الى هولندا الى
اليونان الى اخره وبالتالي دائما الناس
بتعيش تحت ضغط مستمر انا هتفقد وظيفه
عملها دائما في حاله من عدم اليقين ده هو
اللي اشار ميند
بونت في مفهومه اللي سماه لكود مودرنتي او
الحداثه السائله لكن لما كان بيتكلم على
الحدث السائله وصفها بشكل يقدر يساعدنا ان
احنا نفهم اللي بيحصل في الشرق الاوسط
بشكل واضح جدا قال ايه الراجل بيقول
كل شيء متغير
وكل علاقه متقلبه
والثابت الوحيد هو التغير والتقلب
والعلاقات الهشه اسمع الكلام مستحضر
المشهد في الشرق الاوسط
يستانف ويقول لا توجد استراتيجيات متسخه
ولا تحالفات صلبه
فقط علاقات سائله تتغير بين يوم وليله
وتحالفات مؤقته قائمه على مواجهه اخطار
مشتركه او القوه
وهو ده اللي ممكن يوصف لنا شكل العلاقات
اللي موجوده في الشرق الاوسط لا توجد
علاقات صلبه ولكن كلها علاقات هشه متقلبه
والدافع الرئيسي اللي بيحرك دول العالم
دول زعماء دول العالم للمصافحات وللعداءات
والشعور بالخوف كل خائف لانه خائف فمحركه
الرئيسي الرغبه في البقاء سيرفايفل والصرف
والرغبه في المقاضي هي اللي بتدفعه
لفتحه عدوات من الان ثم انهائها بسرعه
وتحول الى صداقات ثم هدد الصداقات والتحول
الى العداء السريع
يعني هذا هو وضع الشرق الاوسط التحالفات
مجنونه
ومع هذه التحالفات المجنونه ان شاء الله
يكون لنا حلقات نفصل فيها كثير من الغاز
الشرق الاوسط تحركات التركيه الازمه
الايرانيه تاثير الاضطرابات التي تجري في
العالم على منطقتنا اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
باذن الله